[Music]
here we go
welcome to New York where people are
waiting in line in 30-degree weather for
camera classes the world is round and so
is the video the spectacles capture
Christopher Columbus would love these
but really the glasses captures circular
video so you can do this when you watch
it back on snapchat in your phone so why
buying spectacles they just seemed like
a fun new idea I'm a fan of wearables so
I figured I'd give it a shot give a
salad maybe one pair sauna why are you
buying spectacles for Christmas kids
want your kids want them they would like
them for good they've they asked for
them one of them has but really what
happened how old eight and 12 because
snapchats only selling these at pop-up
locations through these vending machines
the 130 dollar glasses are going for up
to $800 or more on eBay and Craigslist
if that means you don't get to buy them
through a vending machine that looks
like spongebob squarepants mated with a
minion from Despicable Me still it's a
lot of hype over some pretty simple
technology there's no screen inside or
any voice control just cameras and
glasses so you like it yes I kind of
like um about you boom
I probably at halfback kill ya actually
got the black so how long can you wait
in finding bugs it's 9 a.m. and they're
now turning you down Here I am
yes it's 1 p.m. we're totally four total
hours and they might not let us exactly
not gonna
I'll let you wear them
please don't run away
please don't run away with her